Oh King traces the life of Harper's
magazines youngest editor-in-chief in
his book in search of Willie Morris his
50 minute talk took place at politics
and prose bookstore in Washington DC
okay two tasks one of the original Texas
literary outlaws Larry L King has
written hundreds of articles for among
others Harper's New Times audience
parade the Texas observer in the Texas
Monthly he's the author of 20 notable
works of nonfiction including
confessions of a white racist fiction
the one-eyed man stage plays including
the best little whorehouse in Texas in a
children's book because of Lowe's Oh
Brown with in search of Willie Morris
the mercurial life of a legendary writer
and editor he explores his long
friendship with Morris the youngest ever
editor at harper's magazine and the
author of among other things the
terrific memoir north toward home more
than a biography where facts are laid
out chronologically from birth to death
and leaders are left of the summed up
ports of a person this is an exploration
into the life of an enigmatic individual
a genius for sure but also a man not
wise enough to forestall his own demise
more than that even it's also the story
of a friendship that between the subject
of the book and his chronicler it's also
the story of an age that being the
literary heyday of Harper's when writers
like mr. King Norman Mailer David
Halverson Gay Talese and others were
redefining American journalism just as
America is redefining itself after World
War two Korea and the assassination of
John F Kennedy
Larry L King is also a great customer of
ours here at the store so it's
especially gratifying to get to welcome
him to this stage so please help me
welcome Larry L King reminded of Lyndon
Johnson who used to say when they go to
fuse event reductions he wished his
parents could be there that his father
would have enjoyed it and his mother
would have believed
Oscar Wilde said every great man in this
age attracts his disciples and it's
always Judas who writes the biography
you're looking at Judas
I felt like Judas a number of times as
didn't I discovered things and reported
things that I knew William Morris would
not have wanted said about himself and
about some of his actions but I took
comfort in what Willy used to tell those
of us who wrote for him get it all and
get it right and so that's how I managed
to make myself feel like not quite as
much like Judas as perhaps I should have
will it was a very complex individual he
was not a simple soul as some thought
him to be he could compartmentalize
himself so that everybody knew different
William Ortiz I felt for many years that
I was Willie's best friend in
researching and writing this book I
found that 150 people thought that and
Willy had the talent of making everyone
feel as if they were his best friend it
was the sort of thing that a good
politician can do to rally people to his
flag and you might relish to the flag
without really knowing what the flag
stands for but Willy also was very
inquisitive fella he was interested in
everybody's story and so he wasn't
asking people questions that flattered
him and made them feel like if they were
his good friend so much for that purpose
as he was also to get information and to
learn all he could about everybody else
he had success very very early he was a
big frog in the little part of Yazoo
City Mississippi editor of the school
newspaper flashlight wrote the lyrics to
the school song at age 16 voted
president of the student body most
likely to succeed and the most popular
he was star athlete on the basketball
and baseball teams and he was disc
jockey on the 500 watt radio station WFA
Izzy and Willie used to give this speed
up until I guess almost when he died
that he used to give it station breaks w
faz 12 1300 on your dial with studios
high atop the Taylor & Roberts feed and
seed store in downtown Yazoo City the
date the gateway to the Delta and hero
phase loved to abuse with that but
Willie he wrote a lot about his boyhood
and it sounds as if if you read his
books that he had a Tom Sawyer and Huck
Finn boyhood but it was not really that
simple it was not really that true
a lot of things that he wrote about his
boyhood really had more to do with
fantasy than it did with the realities
his mother who was a very demanding
woman and a very critical woman almost
smothered Willy with her demands not
just when he was a kid but through his
life I read over 200 letters in the
researching this book that his mother
had written to him and it was very
difficult for me to understand just how
she could have been so constantly
critical about him she was afraid of a
lot of things one thing I think that she
was afraid of
almost as if she feared that a town
crier would run through the streets of
Yazoo City telling all of her personal
secrets and one of those secrets was
that although she was unruly about
drinking all the time that she was a
secret in it for herself and to get past
those tough times when he was a kid were
they often indulged in fantasies as he
did then for the rest of his life and
sometimes that did not serve him well
professionally I would like to read a
couple of pages here about from the
introduction of his book that contrast
the two at least two different Willie's
everyone thought they knew it - you did
Willie weeks Morris was a man of many
parts what was it Churchill said of
Russia a riddle wrapped in a mystery
inside an enigma
my friend Willie was a little like that
the private William Morris the brooder
the loner the man who could lose himself
in sleep because wakefulness was too
painful the man who preferred whiskey
oblivion to facing problems the Willie
Morris he hid his telephone in the stove
or refrigerator to muffle its rings and
who called it an instrument of torture
the William Morris he couldn't bear to
say no to writers friends or supplements
and so would over-promised and then have
to dodge or fudge or run away the editor
who assigned the magazine articles and
should they go wrong might avoid the
airing writers rather than conveyed the
bad news the Willie Morris is having
hired both Norman Mailer and David
Halberstam
to cover the 1968 Democratic convention
in Chicago could not bring himself to
tell any to tell either of the two
writers that he had been able only to
get one press pass that the two would
have to share
the Willie Marcie could stick his head
in the sand and think himself invisible
the man who for a time became known in
plain utterly language ugly language and
in more than one place as the town drunk
the man who could be as stubborn and
unyielding as any meal his idol William
Faulkner owned
well that fellow was complex and
puzzling man his adoring public never
met
there's no way to rhyme that private
haunted sometimes terrible terribly
difficult individual with the public
woody Morris of legend the Boy Wonder
youngest editor-in-chief at age 32 of
America's oldest magazine the
glad-hander and shoulder hugger the
Marriott good ol boy from Mississippi
equally at home in Texas saloons and New
York salons the editor who not only was
near-perfect and matching writer to
subject but so a drawing a copy editor
pruning excesses changing a serviceable
word to one of war clarity originality
the writers felt chagrin they hadn't
written it that way will it was the pile
of presents and poets enthusiastic
fellow reveler professional athletes and
rough-and-tumble trial lawyers a
telephone Joker who could imitate almost
anyone well enough to fool and embarrass
his famous friends and other
contemporaries into making self-serving
or pompous take statements an editor who
could and often did write better than
most who wrote for him a man generous
with gifts even when short of funds the
kind and playful Uncle Willie or whom
kiddies doted and who himself loved
kiddies and dogs and cats and all manner
of improbable strays whether they had
four legs or two yet willing himself was
something of a stray he would show up at
any hour of the day or night or wake you
by telephone at any hour of the night
and think nothing of having waked you
never mind that you might have to get up
and go
never mind you about they feeling bad
whatever when he wanted to talk he
wanted to talk but when he didn't order
to talk he could run in a hat and he was
very good at that but the most things
Willy did worked out so well for him
early in his life that when he finally
hit adversity he didn't know how to
handle it but he was a long time getting
to it first day he was the big duck in
the little pond in Yazoo City he went on
in the University of Texas where he
became first called public attention and
became a national figure actually as
editor of The Daily Texan newspaper by
were just fighting censorship he first
would print articles from they were
censored saying he had printed towards
then saying don't walk on the grass
let's water the daisies and when that
wasn't enough to suit him
he finally own one that the faculty
advisor had cancelled he wrote he
published a three column blank space on
the front page with the words this
article censored by the faculty advisor
well naturally you know what happens
every newspaper in America just about
with any pizzazz college papers and
they'll in newspapers got in touch and
wanted a copy of that to publish and it
was published everywhere widely and the
Nation magazine got Willet to write an
article his first national article in
any magazine called Mississippi rebel on
a Texas campus and
but outlining what the fight was all
about Willie went from there to being a
Rhodes Scholar first one at the
University of Texas had produced in
northern a decade and when he came back
from his road scholarship
he became the editor of the Texas
Observer they had been founded by Ronnie
Duggar and the observer was sorely
needed in Texas in the time when Texas
newspaper simply did not publish the
news and took no editorial stance that
went to the right of muscle Aeneid
sometimes it seems to me and the El Paso
Herald post was the only newspaper that
endorsed the liberal Ralph Yarborough
when he ran for governor against Allen
shivers in the 1950s so the observer
performed a very good function and they
actually covered what was happening or
not happening in the Texas Legislature
and Ronnie Duggar and I have had our
differences I once wrote of Ronnie that
he had a sense of humor on par with that
of a firing squad
he didn't take their head too much it
was perhaps a slight exaggeration but
not by much
and he and Willie became very close
Johnson LBJ tried to court Ronnie when
he was sent Majority Leader and he
invited him out to his ranch and courted
him and listened and what he got for his
pains was that dr. Gosai can write an
article about how Johnson had kissed his
Fanny and tried to enlist him in his
causes and Johnson became so disgruntled
he told some staff
if you checked into that boy's bloodline
you'll find a dwarf in there somewhere
so Willy stayed with that job about
almost two years I believe 21 months and
CD of his wife and then was getting her
master's degree in English and at
Stanford and wouldn't went out there for
a little while while there he got a
letter from Jack Fisher had for Harper's
Magazine saying he'd read Willie stuff
in The Observer and he knew his
background and that he himself was
getting ready to retire he wanted to
write some books in this and that and he
thought Willie might be the man to be
his successor and that he would like for
Willie to come see him and they talked
about it
and Willie of course was amazed and
jumped at the opportunity and rode a bus
from California to New York those to go
but he did was hired as an associate
editor for the Magnificent sum of one
hundred and twenty-five dollars a week
and stayed the associate editor for four
years before then becoming
editor-in-chief and it was as
editor-in-chief that he made his mark
and became a national figure I'm trying
to find something here
well I wish I'd been a little better
organized when Willie took that job over
his editor in chief he didn't want to
keep a lot of the older hands on there
and so what I can't find what I'm
looking for now huh what's memory anyway
I think and he invited me after staff
meeting I was living here in Washington
he invited me to come to Washington for
staff meeting after he hired me and
David Halberstam marshal Freddie and
John Corey that's contributing editors
and I didn't want to go to a staff
meeting I didn't Stephanie and I knew
Willie hated him too
so I wondered why he was you know
subjecting me to what he didn't put up
with but I went and I was astounded when
all the old-timers on the staff there
said only at the meeting and I said no
no and Willie said Arnie perturbing
editor mr. Larry King as song you sing
for you he's crazy sure the kid named
Jesus on the five-yard line and this was
something that really always got me to
sing and bars and restaurants and
everywhere else
and I sing it without shame or Talent by
God if so I hold often sang oh the game
was played on Sunday in Heaven's own
backyard
Jesus played right halfback Moses played
right door angels on the sidelines
Christ how they did you when Jesus score
two touchdown against that team from
Hell rock rock rock stay with Christ
stay with Christ Jesus on five
yard-line Moses doing God turn fine stay
with Christ
stay with Christ Oh Thank You Larry
right on with me that's that they're
feeling like fifth place jackasses
County Fair getting all these wooded
looks I'm sure I wouldn't look out from
the other staffers and so as soon as the
meeting was over where they just double
sets statement in there they got a room
shut the door he just doubled over left
did you see the looks on their face I
said no Willie damn it I didn't look at
anybody else what did you do that for
his work don't go straight and I'll buy
you a drink please deserve that he just
kept looking hey Beverly Ben chuckle but
he never would say I finally figured out
that he wanted to get rid of just about
all those people in that room and he
thought that that exhibition was show
him that one in their place
and he's right they were all gone in six
weeks
will they also love to play jokes on
people he could change his voice and not
sound a bit like himself oh yes here I
had just been named a Nieman Fellow at
Harvard which Willie had helped me get
the fellowship and as I'm packing and
getting ready to leave answer the phone
and the secretary said hold on for
Dwight's sergeant mr. Dwight sergeant
well here's the name and curator and so
I changed pleasantries with mr. sergeant
and told him that I was getting ready to
come up in a couple of days and I was
really looking forward to the experience
the adventure well yes the Niemen
curator said and perhaps call coughs to
discreetly I found it's my duty to ask
what I feel it's a rather personal
question I go in mr. King have you ever
been convicted of a felony offense a beg
your pardon
a crime they've here because of a crime
well no good god what's going on here
but it certainly distressing mr. King
but a member of the hard corporation has
received information that your convicted
felon and if so I'm afraid we'd before
three consider your name and fellowship
not that we'd preferred you without
official inquiry and you to stay what
preclude me this is the dumbest thing
I've ever heard your if you'd believe
deny and goddamn variety refuted
there's no need for profanity missed
again I am duty-bound to inquire have
you perhaps been convicted of a
misdemeanor offense one short of a
felony though involved incarcerations no
I don't know so you aren't equipped for
statements in this you never have been
in jail
hello mr. king hello hi mr. sergeant see
I did an amount must just steal his
little kid stuff you know like laughable
things youngsters will do oh dear I find
this so distressing I must ask you to
elucidate well it was for you know
fighting them drinking the little stuff
like that back well not just kids in
Texas you know it's quite common and
culture if that's happened place ha ha
ha
kind of a rowdy frontier culture you
know ha ha
but least we didn't killing Indians
under Dagon house querying a mr.
sergeant I confess to having
accidentally killed me no lo when I was
teenager postman but no charges were
filed
having run over a gas pump in Texas and
that had led their dispute with the
service station owner the cops came yes
and I had been temporarily handcuffed
but released after I agreed to pay
damages and I was just beginning to
confess the peace smart arrest from
Willie church hello Larry you'll outlaw
William Archie sorry sob he seemed to me
a couple of other times yes didn't you
ever suspect him well yes once young
woman told me the whole long for
Governor Nelson Rockefeller now about
Willie Morris knows it too if members of
Rockefeller staff have talked to me
about becoming speech writer for him it
is epidemic presidential campaign so
after governor Rockefeller had made a
short pitch and asked me to catch a
shuttle in New York and that today for a
3 p.m. meeting in his office
I said Cheryl we'll go and soon as I
sprout wings I'll fly to the west coast
and you can go but it stunk
we see it coming don't you it was
dropped out and I don't think that
merely imagine that he's evil for me
almost immediately Wayne when Harper's
Willie resigned from Harper's over a
dispute with management over money
really about the magazine losing money I
don't go into all the details here talk
in the book but that was the first
adversity Willie had faced him this
professional life and he didn't know how
to handle it he resigned not thinking
they would accept his resignation I told
him don't mail a letter with him there's
no wiggle room here they will accept
this no I said they won't it turns out
he'd mailed it before even consulted me
and they did accept it and it tore his
life up he had never had any adversity
in his life before he didn't really know
what to do and he went out to Long
Island sort in self-imposed exile and
didn't get in touch with any of the rest
of us at Harper's for months and months
we didn't even know where he was and
Edie Yoder who had been a Rhodes Scholar
with him found him one to see and said
it will they spent all this time just
want to chitchat didn't want to talk
about anything seriously and listening
to two records one was Nina Simone
singing hint gospel hymns and one was
somebody reading Robert E leaves
farewell to his troops at the end of
Civil War and the southern surrender at
Appomattox and that's a very was a very
sad image to me the end here
and there is still well the book goes on
in covers all over these many downs ups
he's going back to Mississippi and
finally his coming back and writing more
books in the last decade of his life
than he had before I couldn't believe it
when I heard that he had this massive
heart attack and died on August 2nd
1999 and my wife and I and our children
had already booked a trip to Italy and
so I didn't get to go to his funeral
but on the morning of his funeral August
6 99 I woke up and knew what I had to do
and that is at one time I had written a
piece about my little hometown in Texas
where I was born
called Putnam Texas and about how it had
once been a fairly good little town but
had gone downhill this towns will and I
had aligning it would always somehow
like pulled it there once in a while was
this I always thought Putnam would be
eternal in the room had nothing left but
the general store and an old stadium so
I was in Rome today at that funeral and
I knew what had to do I went over to
that old stating and I saying Jesus
don't stuff you're too early and it's if
it's helpful everyone's heard ok I'll
take questions now
you know everything already he came down
we knew of each other had many mutual
friends in politics and writers on the
text observer and so forth but when
Willie first went to Harper's I was
working on Capitol Hill then for
congressman Jim Wright who later became
a House speaker and Willie had heard of
me through mutual friends too as I had
heard of him and read his stuff so he
came down to find some writers in in
Washington and he came to Jim Wright's
office looking for me and here's about
11 o'clock in the morning three eleven
and Willie said I offered him kept the
coffee in he was pretty rank coffee and
he said what is it some who wouldn't go
together
got much good house cafeteria two steps
that's not the jewelry sitting we've got
some flesh wouldn't get something
stronger when I see your man after my
own heart and we went across the street
to the filibuster room of the
Congressional Hotel and eleven o'clock
then then mr. Johnson the black dude who
ran the place in who insisted on being
called mister if you only think you
better call him mister and I did happily
said you know we don't serve in hit
11:30
I said yes I know that mr. Johnson mr.
nothing says you can't
as mr. Morris here has come down to see
the Speaker of the House he hasn't
before which is a lock oh yes he hasn't
a part with the speaker this afternoon
and he's got to all himself up for this
meeting so Johnson didn't quite know
what to do but then I slipped him a
couple of bucks and he begins the era
Airways clear and truth is willing less
rich three hours if he'd had an
appointment neither one of us could have
got the speaker's office with
we'd kept falling down investing in the
other yesterday I just sat dr. Whitley's
best friend well I forgot about that
yeah I'm just curious sim can you hear
from microphone er I'm just curious
the would you describe and with willie
morris and in Long Island if that it
sounds like that began sort of the
decline because when you I've read
everything William Morris wrote in north
toward home I think is just his
literature yeah there's no question but
what will he wrote after that ago I
enjoyed it was certainly nothing close
to that I just wonder if you can talk
about how you think someone he could
write north toward home would not be
able to produce anything really close to
that after that well I think he did
produce a couple of things is fairly
close to that the courting of Marcus
Dupree I thought was a fine book critic
didn't care that much for it they seemed
to think that it was just about a kid
getting football scholarship at Oklahoma
and then busting out and so they just
kind of left it up there was very much
in there about the history of racism in
Mississippi the history of the state of
the particular part of the state that
Dupree came from which was Philadelphia
where you know the three white civil
rights workers were killed and that was
a that was one book and I thought that
his New York days had certain passages
in it that were very good although
Willie did not deal with several
questions that I have tried to deal with
in here about what happened after he
left Harper's and how he got in such a
bad shape at Harper's to in effect have
to resign
and buddy up with his interests in
personality did he ever consider running
for office I talked about that with him
once and he said that in Mississippi in
the time that he would have thought
about running he could not have done so
because he would have had to in effect
embrace segregation and that he couldn't
do that
and Turner Catholic who rose to run the
New York Times of Mississippi and David
Halberstam worked with him too and
worked with Willie he said they were
both alike that way that they could have
been governors or senators in
Mississippi except neither of them could
bring themselves to say and do what
they'd have to say and do to win there's
so much in the book about his
relationship with different dogs and of
course he wrote so movingly about his
dogs and then later a cat but at the end
of the book - you talk about how in
writing about the dogs though and cat
that he is talking about larger themes
and I wondered if you could just talk a
bit about that what he's talking about
change especially the wrote about the
book about the cat I can't remember
cat's name now yes bit McGee read I'm
having a senior moment when he in that
book he talks about we don't talk about
it he illustrates more than it talks
about it but the change brought about he
never liked cats Willie didn't he loved
dogs but he'd never liked cats had never
even thought about him very much but
Joann his second wife his widow was a
cat person he didn't even know that
til somebody gave her one of her
children I think gave her a cat and
Willie said he didn't hurt her seen it
Oh a woman be so happy that she flushed
red and was just excited about that yeah
well that cat had a litter of kittens
and one was under sized probably wasn't
going to live they felt and all that and
Willie something I took that cat over
and fed it with an eyedropper and took
it to the vet and all that and got it
through and he lived and became a good
healthy cat daddy named spit Magee and
he wrote that book about it and spit
McGee's famous such just when he finally
died three or four years after Willie
did The Associated Press wrote in the
bit about it now when Willie's doe
Ichabod Crane died he called me to tell
me and he was so upset about and at that
time was not much of a dog person in
fact I was when I was eight years old to
fairly good-sized dogs attack me and
give me little damage and I was really
afraid of and so I couldn't I couldn't
identify with Willie's calling me and
saying Larry I went out there take my
dog he's in front of York and he was
dead and I didn't know what said you
know dog died you know
and I said well hey well it has an Ole
Miss football team looking he said I
can't talk either all right now any
younger
and I later learned how much that'd hurt
him and later on when I got a little
Shih Tzu I had for eleven years and had
put him down just for his 12 I
understood a little bit about what
Willie had gone through doesn't know
them now it's means to notice it but
what was the rest of the question the
themes yes
personal growth changing from then
though personal capers understanding
other people's point of view you wrote a
lot about that he wrote a lot about
families in home too
there was much of it very wise and very
true although Larry wells down in Oxford
Mississippi said of him will he lived a
life in he wrote a life if the two had
met each other say on a subway platform
I doubt if they would each have
recognized the other and that's probably
true to some extent to anybody else
Willie taught at Ole Miss for a while
yes and apparently didn't like it very
much I was just wondering if that you
know exhilarated his drinking or
affected as Meryl relationships if he
was able to write while he was there if
it pushed him back to writing after he
left he had the first three years he was
down in Mississippi then he was at Ole
Miss at least the first two maybe the
first three yeah he loved being back
home everybody made over him on the news
Willie Morris
except for William Faulkner and Eudora
Welty he was probably the third most
famous writer that Mississippi had
produced and he loved all the attention
he loved being home love the way he was
treated but he hated teaching skill
I understand I went to Princeton state
school once although lawyer friend of
mine in Texas said King you know no they
never taught my school you've never seen
much-talked I'm leaving it I was a high
school dropout a college dropout - and
that was true so and I didn't I didn't
thrive in the classroom Willie didn't
either
and finally what he would do every year
who Willie would refuse to do he takes
something away from what he'd agreed to
do when he came there as a teacher no I
won't do that with anymore I won't give
eight lectures I'll give four okay I'll
bring in three writers of this you're
not six those sort of things and he got
away with it because he was Willie
Morris but he was unhappy there and he
couldn't write much and didn't write
much Joann Pritchard whom he married and
she's the writer and editor herself from
Jackson and that's greatest thing that's
happened to Willie in a long long time
funny story there she had to get Willie
functioning again he was not doing
anything for himself he'd have other
people do everything and as an example
she doesn't work one day and Willie
called her or she'll Joanne you got to
come home come home right now
a tree fell we met a big old tree fell
on the house you got of course you knew
it wasn't so she did she went home
call somebody they came to remove the
trip widow went right back to sleep
but as I said in the book hey will he
done his part he sounded the alarm Helen
that Paul Revere didn't ship with the
mother and how how charged it was how
difficult I'm wondering didn't ever
become more nurturing on the mothers
part or or did it never get anything no
Willie
and he did cry her funeral but I only
know that because it's I'm David right
over but he called her his crazy mother
when he talked to his friends about her
and said he could never live back in
Mississippi as long as she was alive and
he did not go back there to live till
she died and then he told me she died in
77 he told me that he when he went back
to close up the house and do all that
he's an only child that he found just
bottles and bottles of empty vodka
bottles in shoeboxes in closets under
the rug under the bed behind cleaning
stuff under the sink
so it's quite obvious if she drank a lot
David Ray has with his son David very
much says that she called Willy a couple
of times about her drinking worrying
about it and that he suggested that she
see a preacher and that's the only
advice he'd give her because Willy would
never talk to anybody about his own
alcoholism and just wouldn't wouldn't
listen to it Larry as you know it's a
complex relationship sometimes between
writers and editors mystical even dark
did you have a good relationship and was
it inspiring in many ways and in the
second part of the question did he ever
come to you later on and use you as an
editor use me as an editor or an
advising editor kind of thing no he
never did that
I guess he wasn't that desperate but hey
yeah he he was a boy the first party
Jeff was four thirty a question come
back yeah how good of her how creative
did he see for you I mean that he was he
was wonderful I was embarrassed when I
saw him edit my first couple of phases I
had read
as he had he was very good about putting
the right writer over the right subject
- and that was because he was sitting to
talk to the writers and asked him a lot
of questions about different things and
when he had on the subject or they hit
on subject either way and they got to
tell them got in their eyes begins
shining they were getting babble and use
their hands a lot Willie would say you
must write that for me and nine times
out of ten those turned out to be really
good pieces and he really knew how to
get the best out of his right and he
gave you all the space you could use I
mean so long as I don't mean that he
just left you spew words but so long as
you were saying something
he didn't didn't cut down Norman Mailer
you know had a entire issue just about
except for one short piece that I had
and it was the longest piece ever
published in to this date in any
magazine even longer than the New
Yorkers original article of Hiroshima
you mentioned you with the Judas yeah
I'd like you to expand on that how did
you feel that you were the Judas in that
relationship well I mean in writing the
book and in telling so many things about
Willy especially about his drinking he
was terribly protective of his
alcoholism he very angry as I mentioned
or anybody knew it or anything else now
of course he had at least four DWIs duis
that I know about and probably something
that I didn't know about no telling how
many wrecks he had in fact people used
to shudder when they'd see Willy and
truman capote together in the same car
when they both lived out on Long Island
no matter who was driving because dr.
pota hated driving except when he's
drunk and he had so many dents and his
old red car that I rotated look like he
only parties during hailstorm and Willy
left his personal calling cards he had
white car monster timing Oh miss and
according to hood friend down there we
left his personal calling card loose but
she's a white pain don't ever faculty
car parked on a lot over that and so
that sort of stuff Willie wanted
everybody to love him and liked him
and to think that he had absolutely no
weaknesses he wanted people believe that
he was always in charge of himself and
of everything else and we'd all like
that to be thought but no no none of us
can have it done I don't know who my
Judas would be our problem he's
important have to have one we're from
Mississippi and in fact from Yazoo City
are you but and it was you know they're
well-known among the people there that
he had the drinking problem so I
wondered if it was more than that I knew
that you had revealed them no that's
that's the main thing that was it wasn't
um your relationship no no we're
fistfight once over a woman I wasn't
fighting he got some woman although
although not for long so neither
Nathan Evers really won on that and we
didn't see each other or communicating
anyway for two years after that so it
was more than just a little Smitty thing
it happened in 72 and finally in 74 I
had a book come out called the old man
and a lesser mortals it was a collection
the pieces and I decided just send
Willie one with a warm inscription and
see if that would open the door a little
and sure enough it did he called me
almost immediately and we never either
one of us ever referred to the fight
again and picked up our relationship
went off pretty well mr. King I'm one of
those tight-lipped Baptist from Yazoo
City but I will admit that I enjoyed the
song yeah it wasn't really very good but
my question is did Joann have any
influence on him very much in these last
10 years as far as the drinking was
concerned uh not as much as she would
like to help she did get him slowed down
but she found it impossible to get him
to quit there was just no way and she
told me that she decided okay if she
could make him eat right and keep him
home at night instead of him being out
you know wandering in drunk all night
and getting in Rex and DWIs and all that
that's about the most she could hope for
so that's what she did and she was
successful to that extent yes I think
his best town his life he said it was
after
well I guess we're getting better ready
to wine this thing down there believes
you got some money's worth
okay then I'll sign some books I want to
thank all the ole incident coming out
it's I saw this pretty weather today not
though goddammit assistance to go p22
nice and people are not going to show up
they want to be outdoors okay go ahead
I thought I heard you say that that
north toward home was good but have a
lot of fantasy in it and I was sorry to
hear that I didn't grow up in yes no I
didn't say that about north or at home
oh you generally I didn't grow up in
Yazoo City but I grew up in a little
southern town that was a lot like Yazoo
City and that book resonated so that
book I think was a very true book it was
it later in life that and it's kind of
strange I thought but will it begin
fantasize more in books in and as I told
him how I told him this - that being
diplomat that he always wrote of a
greener world and God had made and I
think he sometimes did okay thank you
very much Willie Morris was
editor-in-chief of Harper's from 1967 to
1971
for more on Harper's and its history
visit harper's org